[Musique]
c'est du jamais vu
le village touristique au pied du mont
tremblant complètement désert
ici tout est encore fermée la vie s'est
arrêtée le 15 mars quand la station de
ski a mis fin à sa saison
cinq semaines plus tôt que prévu
l'impact de perdre le mois de mars comme
on a fait un effet dévastateur pour tous
les commerçants sur la montagne chant
nos dans nos à un hôtel et trois
restaurants en bas de la montagne où les
frais fixes pour les commerçants dit il
s'élève chaque mois à près de 80 dollars
pour chaque pieds carrés d'espacé occupé
un des endroits les plus chers au canada
en ce moment la réalité c'est que on n'a
aucun revenu le plus longtemps que les
femmes aient le moins de chances qu'ils
y en a qui vont avoir pour survivre
jusqu'aux des frais à mont tremblant
l'industrie touristique rouler sur l'or
avec 3 millions de visiteurs et des
revenus de 300 millions de dollars par
année
joe au lendemain tout s'arrête toutes
ses formes la parsemer partout je pense
que l'économie déjà est basé sur le tout
reste ici que du moment où ce qui est
pas ça ça va être très très difficile
pour la région
sébastien hall sait bien que son service
de traiteur va souffrir d'un été sans
événement sportif ni festival et son
restaurant risquent de ne pas accueillir
de touristes étrangers
c'était un contexte qui est pas évident
le frac pour voir vraiment ce encourager
localement régionalement pour pouvoir
arriver à passer au travers cette crise
là les québécois qui représente 60 % de
la clientèle de mont tremblant sont donc
espéré cet été on pense que les gens qui
voudront sortir du du confinement vont
chercher des espaces verts comme ici des
de la nature allait marcher dans la
forêt alors on pense que notre
destination sûre populaire à ce niveau
là pour venir en vélo de montagne en
randonnée la location de chalets ou
d'embarcations nautiques ainsi que le
cam pin ou le golf pourrait aussi être
des activités envisageable en temps de
pandémie tremblant est donc en bonne
position mais daniel blier demain
réaliste nous ce qu'on vit présentement
c'est pas tellement la quantité de
touristes mais plutôt de capable
d'accueillir les gens qui vont venir ici
de façon sécuritaire avec des bonnes
normes sanitaires
sauf que la règle des 2 mètres entre
chaque client inquiète beaucoup les
restaurateurs de la région un restaurant
s'y est pas remplie à 90% séduction d'y
arriver
les marges de profit sont tellement sont
tellement minime on parle de 10 % ça
c'est si tout va bien plus connu est
bonne la viabilité de serre pour les
commerçants va être très très très dur
la vie puis je suis certain qu'il y en a
qui vont même se demander ça vous tue la
peine de rouvrir dans ces conditions là
[Applaudissements]
quoi qu'il en soit l'arrivée des
premiers visiteurs à tremblant cette
semaine après la levée des barrages a
suscité de l'espoir mais aussi un peu de
peur ça va faire vivre l'économie le
monde grâce à travailler pour saluer un
semblant de vie normale
les montréalais devraient rester chez
eux un peu plus longtemps c'est
possiblement surtout si on du secteur
home naturellement mais on sait qu'il y
en a qui sont déjà venus à cachette dans
la région vous demandez bassiana fonds
qui à mesure qu'on va trouver les bonnes
façons que le bonhomme ans venu nous
donner les bonnes directives en nombre
et les secteurs en conséquence mont
tremblant a réussi son confinement et ne
veut surtout pas rater son déconfinement
ici on espère secrètement une saison
touristique à partir du 24 jours